alright let's talk briefly about James
Comey there's a lot more to get to
including part two of my interview with
Michael Shermer you'll remember Trump
fired FBI director James Comey Comey
said he'd be willing to testify to
Congress as a private citizen only if it
was a public hearing last week after
call me was fired Senate Intelligence
Committee asked Comey to testify behind
closed doors Comey declined he doesn't
want to do it behind closed doors
yesterday in the wake of the news that
number one that a special prosecutor has
been appointed in number two we learned
48 hours ago that James Comey was asked
by Donald Trump reportedly to end the
investigation into Michael Flynn now
Senator Richard burr and ranking member
Mark Warner Republican and Democrat
respectively from the Senate
Intelligence Committee have said we are
ok with James Comey testifying in public
as long as he also does a closed session
I hope you will accept this invitation
Richard burr hopes that Comey will
accept this invitation there will be
questions about the Russia investigation
there will be questions about commis
abrupt firing normally when you have
public testimony at these Senate panels
there's not exactly high TV ratings this
could be the record breaking ratings for
a former intelligence official testified
before a Senate panel couldn't it yeah
and also at these Senate panels usually
it's hyper partisan so the Democrats and
past testimonies when it came to James
Comey would ask about Russia
yeah whereas the Republicans would ask
about the gala regimes that Obama
wiretap Trump or Hillary Clinton I think
you're getting to a point now where even
the Republicans have to ask about the
2016 election and if Trump and the
Russians colluded it's almost starting
to look weird if they don't ask about it
when might this happen could be as soon
as next week Jake Sherman from Politico
tweeted earlier today or late yesterday
quote jason Chaffetz just told me he has
scheduled a hearing for next Wednesday
and is inviting James Comey so maybe
Comey will do both of these the the
hearing the public hearing and the
closed one will have to see I actually
think you sort of need the close
testimony because he's not going to be
able to talk about everything publicly I
do think it's important to have the
public one to put
public face on the fact that he's
showing up there and is willing to
testify I'd like to see both I think
it's also important to get him on record
talking about how Trump asked him to end
the Michael Flynn investigation and even
the part about him requesting that
journalists who publish classified
information beyond Ferrazzi in prison
yeah it's outrageous and as I've talked
to you before the contemporaneous notes
of FBI agents are considered to be
reliable testimony and it's actually a
sign of someone who takes what they're
doing seriously I mean this is something
business people do this is something
doctors do lawyers right after a meeting
you jot down your notes about it because
then if you need to review it six months
later your recollection won't be perfect
and the fact that James Comey did this
doesn't strike me as suspicious it
strikes me as making him even more
trustworthy and there will be no
shortage of time to analyze what it is
that Comey
ultimately says you can discuss this
along with anything else that's on your
mind on our reddit discussion forum
david pakman.com slash reddit today's
episode of the david pakman show is made
possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS